[Music]
all right so
netflix is no not netflix ooh apple tv
plus how
cute i've never seen you do that ever it
was like the first word that came out of
it
that's so cute thank you thank you so
much because they don't even have apple
tv plus
yes we do they gave it to us for free
for a year i think free for a year we
haven't
i've never gone on that thing this is
what casey did in real life
what's apple tv plus it's like their own
stream they got that show with uh
jennifer anderson and steven carrell
jason momoa has a show
i don't watch tv [ __ ] that i know
there's so much now that like so much
like streaming platforms and content i
can't keep up anymore
but this docu-series that apple tv plus
is releasing
is i think a little more uh what do you
say more
insightful i think of our american
lifestyles
american [ __ ] so that yeah so the show
is called becoming you
and it highlights the first five years
of a hundred different children from
all around the world uh that's cool uh
south america
to mongolia like just even
in like america like but like about it
more unique places
what about it the idea is that they're
saying the first five years
of a kid you know
did that in a child development class
that the first five years
first seven programs everything yeah
every
everything else is based off that
framework
the first seven years because your
understanding of the world
is programmed mainly within those five
years how you trust people
everything for sure and the rules of the
programs
are uh wrote written in that you don't
have the ability to question anything
for the first three
everything the sensations that you
download like from touch and oh this is
hot this works like this oh mommy and
daddy does this and this is how you
trust people
first three years yes then you start to
kind of formulate thoughts and stuff
like that
beyond that that's beautiful because
that's exactly what the show has honed
in on and it's starting to create
a dialogue that i think the producers of
the show are hoping that american kind
of can can self-reflect yeah
because in america there's a lot of
coddling of of our children you know we
don't
allow our children to do things we think
the world is a lot more dangerous
and maybe maybe rightfully so many
statistics indicate that you know
american lifestyles
i blame our media because they're always
scaring us true
because like for example you know how
you told us about in japan
they have toddlers going out and running
errands yeah they buy cigarettes and
they smoke a little bit
no but they do but they did buy
cigarettes yeah but like that just forms
for dad it programs independence already
so young
and over here we can't send our kids out
to the [ __ ] store they're gonna get
kidnapped by pedophiles because the
media is always telling i mean probably
it's true probably it's probably true
like also it doesn't help how we're just
always like
fearing yeah i was in singapore yeah
last september and we were at
we were in this town that my mom grew up
grew up in and we saw like they were
probably eight years old they just got
out of school
these two little girls and they got off
the bus together and they're like all
right see you later and they just both
walked home by themselves and
we just tripped the [ __ ] out it's like
that in taiwan too yeah and i'm like yo
where are their parents but my mom was
like yo that's what they do kids get out
of school they go to restaurants by
themselves get
food or whatever or like you know street
vendors and then they go to their after
school academy and they don't
come home until nine or ten yeah did you
guys do that what do you mean did you do
that like when you were kids in america
hell no
i did i did yeah yeah i did we played on
our street though i played in my
neighborhood i didn't go out into the
city
oh yeah we like i would walk to the with
my brother to the gas station and we buy
candy
it was like a mile away and then there
was an in and out right next to the gas
station and i would go order a milkshake
how old were the other two yeah eighth
[ __ ] really so that's the late bloomberg
because they're talking about the first
five years yeah
i'm under five nights late bloomberg i
didn't do that until i was like 13. my
guy
so this is really looks like he's age
three
and in japan that's a big three-year-old
man that's like taika
yeah yeah you're right but yeah he's
three years is he picking his butts
yeah yes he has got an itchy butt so he
doesn't know how to wipe properly
but apparent his dad on this particular
day of the filming of the documentary
uh it was like his first aaron i don't
know what the translate or like what it
what the word japanese word is but it's
translates as first errand
oh cool so he sends three-year-old
intent oh
i was just talking about ten-month-old
to go buy lunch for his family that's
around the time
you start sending them off to doing
errands by by the way i wish our country
was safe enough to do that well if you
okay you know we've all been to japan
right and like
well the do you know how the
it's like around the block yeah it's
really downstairs from wherever you're
staying at
there might even be a 7-eleven right
there yeah so
it's not like here where you gotta go
far as [ __ ] you gotta go super far
and then over there um because
everyone's doing this like the trains
the bathrooms
everything is set to that way that's why
everything's so small
yeah that like when you go to the
bathroom there's like the the sinks are
like [ __ ]
like you got to kneel yeah it's before
they're like hurting my back trying to
walk
like though even if things weren't far
away like when you go to a hotel i
couldn't even fathom sending a
three-year-old to go to the lobby
and like request something like that so
because
here you think the kid's gonna get
snatched yeah like that's the last time
i'm gonna see my kid
bye you know i don't know maybe
kidnapping and pedophilia is just
more in america maybe maybe that's why
it's scary it's just america there's
other countries too
but like maybe not japan pedophiles
exist everywhere right but like maybe
they don't have
a kidnapping problem like we do maybe
what is the root
or maybe the pedophile all right the
pedophiles and other countries are more
disciplined they could resist
that's what i'm saying like they know
not to do that that open you know if
they're able to resist
and then maybe they're scared that make
him a pedophile then they resist girls
get touched up on the trains there it's
not like
they're perverts like they they exist
you know but maybe they don't want kids
maybe they
they want what is wrong with america
true yeah but the thing is
this is pretty common and then my mom
didn't really see the difference in the
two countries
so she would send me off she's like all
right it's time for you to learn how to
like go to the store
and she goes you gotta get three i
forgot how old i was get set back
i don't even i don't have this memory
because that's how young i was okay she
told me
that she gave me a list i went to the
store i did all this you were able to
read
yeah that young how old yeah though she
tells me what it is
when did you start reading i don't
remember i don't know oh that just
sounds really good i don't know
it was three but maybe four or five but
like it's just taika read
hell no he's two joe's a genius we never
knew
yeah he is though i could be fine you
were advanced for american standards
okay
maybe i think tyco's learning his own
[ __ ] he knows the planets and
galaxies and all that [ __ ] true but the
first thing i was able to read was
japanese and it's easy it's like abc's
it's like phonetic it's not like um
characters yeah so in mongolia you're so
cute
there's another three-year-old and her
name is
where they live um they have a very
rural area of mongolia
and they have to go collect ice to melt
to
for cooking purposes so at her age
that's what she's
you know tasked to do uh you know for
her family
and um in this documentary the scene
plays out where
i guess on her own accord she realized
that she could
possibly bring back more ice for the
village
if she teamed up with someone else and
so i documented her ability to
ask a friend resourceful and actually
say hey
if we work together we could probably
bring back way more ice we could
probably cook way more
when does this come out i mean i want to
watch it
critical thinking yeah at her age that's
what's missing in this country
i don't have i have zero of it i
absolutely love this
dude you know those videos where you see
those chinese kids with a [ __ ] wok
they look like a chinese restaurant with
a cigarette in their mouth like they're
just
have you seen those videos where they're
they're cooking to music
and they're all like dancing like
chinese yeah like chinese music
it's a it's mind-blowing you look
younger than taika yeah yeah
with some nutrition deficiencies that we
don't know about
do they actually contribute to their
family imagine like
we're so coddled man that's so true and
then this one's pretty intense so this
is uh
pilo and he is from uh borneo
borneo borneo yeah and uh what he was
tasked to do was to
gather coconuts and also to open
coconuts wow
damn so in the in the his segment of the
story he takes oh well
one he kind of like has to figure out
how to open it and i think
he he carries a machete wow he doesn't
want to use it he's scared it's scary
so he tries smashing it on the floor he
does a lot of different other things
but ultimately realizing the only real
way to open this thing and
preserve the meat in the water is to
just hack it open with a machete so at
age three
he's learning how to hack open a coconut
with a machete that's insane did your
parents
allow you guys to use stuff no my mom
i'm looking back she let me use a lot of
[ __ ] i was making coffee for my mom when
i was like
really i was less than five years old
that kids aren't supposed to use
uh well i was using the stove yeah i was
using a stove boiling water and making
coffee yeah i'd make rice crispy treats
yeah me too as a three-year-old i mean
she
she was there when i was three but like
i was like a five-year-old
i would say yeah yeah it's hard to trust
the kid when they eat
ice cream and it's still here you know i
mean i'm like okay this is houseful eats
ice cream chocolate dude that happens to
me now i haven't seen you until this
date yeah that's true that's why he
can't cook at home they don't let them
know that's why i don't do no choice
around that
i mean what's the american kid do
what does he attend oh yeah well
american kids i feel like
are very good at figuring out algorithms
and
and
finding recommended three at age three
is very good with the ipad that's
something that these kids don't know how
to i mean i could use the remote control
when i was three but like that was our
version of it but
programming oh not about programming i
bet you could trade he plays the slot
machine on the ipad
that's tight that's good yeah learning
how to gamble already yeah
it's important skill to get to feed the
machine you know true
i remember cutting my hand a lot from
cutting oh my gosh
you know what i was really good at as a
kid taking metal objects and putting
them into sockets that's what i was
thinking
wow your parents let you do that you did
that more than once
i did that like three or four you've
never electrocuted yeah oh my god
now i haven't done like one time i can
understand you're curious
but more than once you're just stupid as
a kid there we had we were
fortunate enough to have a pool and i
would always like i didn't
know how to swim but i brought the
toaster in there yeah yeah and i was
like see what happens
with an extension core too so i was
ahead of my time smart no but uh
i would like kind of [ __ ] around and
like pretend to like
hop in the pool or like put my toe in
and my mom would be like yo what the
[ __ ] are you doing like get away from
the pool
and i'd always like test her and her
thing was like she would count
and i'd be like yeah yeah whatever and i
would like mock her as she was counting
i would say
but then also i would fall in the pool
pretty regularly because
like my sisters would have to like get
me out of the pool while you were
drowning yeah
you did
at least you were a kid my brother fell
in the pool several times with his phone
in his pocket and my parents had to
replace his phone
and they didn't get in trouble they just
replaced his phone how old was he
like 20. what wow like
oh well i guess college yeah college age
yeah so
19 20. jeez
[Music]
do